et bien bonsoir à toutes et à tous
bienvenue à ce rendez-vous de la
démocratie nous avons une prochaine
séance le 9 avril
nous entendrons jacques de saint victor
qui vient nous parler de la sortie un
livre intéressant et important sur le
rôle des mafias en démocratie et pas
seulement en italie
ce sera un peu la suite logique de ce
que nous avons dit l'autre jour avec
marc lazar sur les résultats et les
considérations qu'on doit en tirer des
élections italienne ou notamment sur le
lait je dirais le double ou le
leu compliquer le complexe populisme
nessma entre berlusconi et gris youn a
été je crois assez utilement
relever dans ce soir françois bayrou
fait le fait le plaisir de
d'être avec nous comme tout à tour
chaque rendez-vous de la démocratie mais
pour parler plus
particulièrement de son livre de la
vérité en politique
moi je dirais qu'il est bien dans le
droit fil de ses précédents travaux
je ne cite que les titres et il sent
tous évocateur il se sent chaîne très
pour arriver aujourd'hui à la vérité en
politique nous soit la relève en 2000 un
projet d'espoir en 2007
abus de pouvoir en 2009 état d'urgence
en 2011 est la france solidaire en 2012
et donc aujourd'hui alors moi je dirais
que tout y est et n'est ce pas il tout
françois bayrou non dans ce livre il ne
manque pas un bouton de guêtre n'est ce
pas il y a
il ya les trois ordres et pascal il y à
du pegi comme il en faut et il y à même
la définition de la démocratie par marc
sangnier donc
nous soucier du niveau tant bat pageas
de notes en vache pattes
tout y est et sur bon vous le savez
toute une série d'idées force que je ne
détaille pas et que nous retrouvons
intacte très vibrante dans ce dans cette
liste comment dire
je pense que nous aurons beaucoup de
questions à lui poser et elles vont être
d'ordre divers est à la fois gérer des
questions de fond qui touche quasiment
la philosophie la science politique
où est la morale en politique
autour de ce thème quand même qu'il
abhorre mais qu'il n'a pas le temps ni
l'envi de de développer c'est quand même
et ça ce serait je pense aux nues un des
premiers éléments de débat c'est le
rapport que françois bayrou est habillé
depuis tant d'années entre eux
et avec tant de je dirais de
d'arrière-plan de sa famille politique
bien sûr
pierre mendès-france souvent cités dans
ce livre
charles de gaulle bien sûr et
raymond barre d'un sur jacques delors
également c'est la question du rapport
entre la vérité et ce réel que nous
tentons d'appréhender constamment et qui
nous bouscule constamment parce qu'il se
la thèse de jean jaurès intitulé de la
réalité du monde sensible et tout était
dans le sensible et donc pour ma part
j'aurais beaucoup envie de
provoquer un peu françois bayrou en
lisant
dans le rapport entre la vérité en
politique et la réalité telle qu'elle
est telle qu'elle clapote constamment à
travers des crises des confrontations
des affrontements dépit polarisation que
sais-je quelle est la part de là
l'appréhension sensible du politique sur
cette espèce de magma qu'il faut
absolument ordonnée et là il faut une
vision et vous leviez jean françois
belleau le dit bien bien sûr il y a une
part irréductible dans la réalité mais
il nous faut une vision de la réalité et
ça c'est je crois dans les premières
pages du livre alors que j'en reste là
sur les grandes considérations mais
en quoi et comment la vérité impose
qu'il y est une juste une juste vision
du réel c'est votre formule nous n'en
sommes tous là nous cherchons tous cela
dès lors que aussi c'est vrai les
historiens savent trop bien n'est pas là
la réalité n'est jamais qu'appréhendé
par nos nos sensibilités et la vérité
ben on approche pas à pas et en fonction
des périodes d époque bon il ya là tout
a un immense enjeu
mais politique le livre de françois
signal et que sur lequel nous aurons
nous des des questions à lui poser il y
aura plein de bien d'autres j'imagine et
notamment sur l'ailé l'état de ce pays
les choix qu'il a faits au deuxième tour
de la présidentielle de 2002 l'an
dernier mais je n'en dis pas plus vous
avez aussi
noir sur blanc est constamment
son appel bien connu qui pour lui tout à
fait fondamentale comment au fond 1 un
chef de l'état doit être aussi jeudi sa
très cavalièrement mais c'est plus
profond que ça comment un chef de l'état
doit être ou devrait être un père de
famille au cinéma
et comment on appelle à l'union
c'est quasiment un appel à l'union
sacrée comme en temps de guerre n'est ce
pas que que ce livre nous nous nous
propose comment on appelle à l'union
sans prononcer parce que est rom trop
goliat je ne sais pas sans prononcer le
mot de rassemblement françois ça sera
aussi une question qu'on pourra
peut-être avoir à vous poser un autre
avait utilisé la formule de
rassemblement du peuple français nous le
savons bien il ya là encore là toute une
série de questions je dirais d'actualité
d'urgence et d'urgence nationale on
pourrait aussi aller très loin dans dans
la discussion du rapport que vous faites
dans ce livre entre le peuple le peuple
qui est très présent dans les cent
premières pages et puis par un
glissement qui est évidemment attache à
attacher rattaché à la à l'article 3 de
la déclaration des droits de l'homme
n'est ce pas l'exercice de la
souveraineté de ce peuple c'est dans la
nation lors de ce cheminement
peuple-nation démocratie voilà de
manière un peu abstraite c'est aussi
quelque chose qui courent et qui est le
le fil conducteur de ce livre et c'est
pour ça que françois vous avez toute
votre place
fondamentale dans un débat comme celui
ci ce soir dans un rendez-vous de la
démocratie
merci beaucoup jambière
alors je veux pas lui faire moi même
je peux faire moi même le
l'exégète de mes propres oeuvres livre
mais avant ce que vous avez signalé y en
avait un autre qui est reliée à celle
qui s'appelle le droit au sens qui est
alors je parle ici d'un temps que les
moins de 20 ans n'ont aucune chance de
connaître et donc et donc la plupart de
ceux qui sont ici
sont tout à fait sont tout à fait
excuser ou en tout cas expliqué de ne
pas en avoir souvenir mais c'était aussi
un livre où je réfléchissais à ces
sujets alors
quel est le sujet de ce livre alors
surtout parce que les journalistes
quelquefois un peu superficielle 10
je ne dis pas ma vérité en politique
pas un livre sur
la vérité que je porterai
ceux qui sont debout peuvent s'asseoir
il reste quelques places
plus confortable que la station
verticale
et donc
c'est pas du tout ça
d'abord parce que j'ai pas voulu me
donner le ridicule décrire françois
bayrou la vérité en politique
mais ça s'appelle de la vérité en
politique alors le 2 comme vous savez
c'est du latin ça veut dire au sujet 2 à
propos d'eux la vérité en politique
parce que je ne traite pas du tout
ça boume beaucoup je sais pas pourquoi
je ne traite pas du tout d'une vérité
que je défendrai je dis
la vérité
c'est à dire je vais vous lire la
citation de la grande philosophe hannah
arendt que je mets en air en exergue de
ce livre c'est à dire le réel anaran dit
nous pouvons appeler vérité ce qu'on ne
peut pas changer
et je suis persuadé
qu'il y à là quelque chose de tout à
fait essentiel
à la démocratie
du 21e siècle et je vais essayé de
m'expliquer sur ces sujets
mais ce livre et répond à une question
vous savez le
ya des gens qui écrivent des livres pour
dire ce qu'ils pensent moi j'écris des
livres pour savoir ce que je pense je
veux dire pour savoir un peu plus de
manière un peu plus approfondie et et
affiné ce que sont mes intuitions on a
tous des intuitions la politique des
sentiments des deals mais quand vous
êtes quand vous forcez quand vous suivez
la discipline qui consiste à traduire en
termes compréhensibles par tous ce que
c'est pas du tout un livre de
philosophie abstraite c'est un livre qui
est fait pour la lecture
des citoyens et donc
ce livre répond à une question
pourquoi est ce que la france qui était
le premier pays d'europe il y a quinze
ans à la fin des années 90 en est où est
nommé aujourd'hui
ça ça devrait être une question pour
tout le monde
parce que
un pays qui a des atouts formidables
c'est pas la peine de les énumérer un
pays qui a une histoire une culture une
identité une jeunesse
de une deux une diversité
des savants des prix nobel de médailles
fields
tout ça
pour nous retrouver où nous en sommes
c'est à dire
j'hésite à le dire comme dans les années
30 un pays incapable de s'auto suffire
puisque on ne dit pas on parle y compris
mois de déficit du commerce extérieur de
déficit de la balance des paiements ceux
des termes savants technocratique
économistes pour initiés mais la vérité
c'est que ça veut dire que nous ne
réussissons pas à nous auto suffire
alors que autour de nous
tous les pays du même niveau
montre chaque - et chaque année que au
contraire eux
ils réussissent à
propager leur production leurs services
leurs entreprises tout au travers de
l'europe et du monde
j'ai pas besoin de rappeler les chiffres
parce que j'ai depuis longtemps compris
que les chiffres ne convainquait que
ceux qui étaient convaincus
ce que c'est tellement abstrait mais la
france pour la deuxième année
consécutive
70 milliards de déficit du commerce
extérieur
60 milliards de déficit de la balance
des paiements
70 milliards pardonnez moi de faire cet
exercice qui doit vous lasser mais quand
même ça mérite qu'on y réfléchisse et
70000 millions d'euros
pris sur
pas seulement sur jean pierre rioux mais
aussi sur jean pierre rion sur vous tous
sur toutes nos familles
sur toutes nos capacités
pour être apportée à nos fournisseurs
au passage
il ya toujours une question économique
qui est mais est ce que le pouvoir
d'achat baisse
est toujours le gouvernement et l'insee
vous dites mais n'ont pas du tout les
pouvoirs d'achat ont augmenté ces
dernières années excusez moi moi je suis
un
un homme deux l'arithmétique
dans un pays qui est à 0% de croissance
quand le nombre des foyers augmente de
1,5 pour cent par an
ça veut dire que les foyers
s'appauvrissent tous les ans on peut me
faire tous les calculs sympathique
subtil
complètement échevelé
qu'on voudra c'est comme ça que ça veut
dire
pendant ce temps donc nous 70 milliards
de déficit de pertes
pendant ce temps l'allemagne c'est pas
la peine de le rappeler 200 milliards
d'excédents
mais la suisse
0 % de chômage ou 3,8 c'est à dire zéro
et il y à tous les jours trois cent
mille travailleurs qui traversent la
frontière venant de france pour aller en
suisse et qui n'échangerait pas pour un
empire la situation qu'ils ont la main
chez nous il n'y a pas de matière
première en suisse
les salaires on nous explique toujours
que c'est les salaires qui sont la cause
de la situation du pays les salaires en
suisse qui sont combien 40% plus élevé
que les salaires chez nous c'est pas une
paille au moins 30
beaucoup plus élevé que chez nous
c'est une population réduite
c'est pas un pays qui a un niveau de vie
inférieur au nôtre il est très supérieur
au nôtre ça devrait nous poser des
questions l'autriche
excédentaire largement la belgique
excédentaire les pays-bas excédentaire
je fais je fais le tour 1
excusez moi je vais dire quelque chose
qui va vous stupéfié
l'espagne excédentaire
l'italie excédentaire
excédentaire chacun de ces pays dans ses
échanges avec nous france
alors si on trouve que ça va et qu'il
faut continuer comme ça on a le droit
mais qu'on ne se plaignent pas
et donc ma thèse est que nous avons un
problème
spécifiquement français
comme vous voyez je défends devant vous
quelquefois en votre nom le contraire de
ce que défendent tous les autres parce
que les autres et vise c'est la faute de
l'europe c'est la faute de l'euro c'est
la faute de la mondialisation c'est la
faute de notre niveau de vie non
c'est
la responsabilité
de c'est la faute d'un certain nombre de
choix d'organisation de la société
française qui nous bloque dans notre
capacité nationale
c'est ça la question à laquelle j'ai
essayé de répondre dans ce livre est
alors une fois qu'on a ça devant
l'esprit
et c'est pas des pays à tous en bonne
santé que je décris mais c'est un fait
prouver je
n'invente rien il ne
surévaluent rien une fois qu'on a 10 ans
à tout phénomène ya des causes
alors c'est une idée que les politiques
ne retiennent pas souvent
l'idée que à une situation donnée il ya
une cause
d'une idée qui semble pas les effleurer
bossuet avait autrefois vrai que j'ai
des auteurs
l'aigle de mots
bossuet avec une phrase formidable il
disait j'essaie de citer exactement le
ciel se rit des prières que lui font
ceux qui se plaignent de maux dont ils
persistent à vouloir les causes
la situation du pays c'est ça si vous
refusez de regarder les causes des
problèmes alors n'allez pas vous
plaindre au ciel quel que soit votre
ciel même si vous n'en avez pas n'allez
pas vous plaindre tout court
j'ai trouvé une réponse entre nous que
je trouve irrésistible à tous les
journalistes qui me lisent mais monsieur
bayrou ce que vous racontez mais bien
sûr vous avez raison d'abord je dis stop
arrêtez vous là
vous êtes sûr que j'ai raison ben quand
même ça mérite qu'on s'arrête une
seconde et qu'on réfléchisse bien mais
si c'est pas ça ils disent
bon pour dont ils disent pas dire mon
pot mais enfin
on voit qu'il ya quelque chose de cet
ordre dans leurs yeux ils disent mais la
bipolarisation
mais on peut pas faire autrement
eh bien je dis ne vous plaignez pas si
vous considérez qu'on ne peut pas faire
autrement alors applaudissez
venez au micro et expliquer aux gens que
tout va bien mais les gens ne le croire
ou pas
donc pour moi il faut essayer de
comprendre les causes
et ses causes sont donne aux règles
d'organisation de la société française
alors je vais essayer de dire pour moi
la cause principale qui exclut le qui
empêche notre pays de conduire la
politique dont nous avons besoin et que
d'autres ont conduites autour d'îlots
pour trouver cette puissance qui est en
nous et que nous n'arrivons pas à faire
sortir
l'idée que je défends dans le livre
c'est celle ci
lorsqu'il y a besoin au 21ème siècle en
tout cas on peut discuter pour le passé
j'y reviendrai si ça vous intéresse
lorsqu'il est besoin
de conduire une politique de réformes ça
ne peut pas se faire sans le soutien ou
au moins l'assentiment du peuple
en tout cas en france
est en tout cas au 21ème siècle
alors je vais essayer de dire pourquoi
dans les autres pays
il ya une conception de la démocratie qu
est une démocratie de représentation de
délégation le rôle du citoyen et de
choisir une fois tous les quatre ans une
fois tous les cinq ans les
représentants
qui vont aller discuter et décider en
son nom et il ya une clause de revoyure
on revient dans quatre ans et on voit si
vous avez bien fait ou pas entre temps
nous les peuples on va s'occuper de nos
affaires
c'est vrai dans les pays scandinaves
tu as été longtemps vrai
c'est vrai dans les pays de culture
protestante
faudrait examiner pourquoi faire
compliqué mais c'est vrai
entendez-vous entre politiques
ou bien prenez les décisions politiques
et nous les peuples on reviendra pour
voir les résultats
et c'est vrai hadorn ou en france par
dont j'aurais pas fidélité nous enfants
c'est le contraire
depuis la révolution française nous
avons pris une habitude que je considère
fondées c'est que nous voulons nous
occuper de nos affaires nous citoyens
et que nous considérons
que ceux qui sont les puissants
on a un droit de regard sur eux
mêmes si on regarde bien
il ya sur leurs coûts discrètement
découper suivant le pointillé
c'est une idée que nous avons gardé de
la révolution alors maintenant
évidemment c'est plus physique
ce n'est plus
mais c'est moral
on veut savoir on a un droit de regard
plus encore on est
salée puissant n'y pense jamais les
citoyens en eux ils ont sonné nous
sommes le peuple souverain m'a écrit ça
dans la constitution
la légitimité viala du peuple
pour le peuple par le peuple
tout ça a été créé dans nos textes
fondamentaux
personne ne peut s'arroger
le droit de décider
une partie de la nation peut pas décider
à la place de l'autre
et on rend la justice au long du tout ça
c'est la france ça vient de loin mais
cette histoire de la révolution
française ça nous a quand même marqué
assez profondément
donc nous sommes un peuple je veux pas
dire de démocratie directe
parce que ça voudrait dire des
référendums tout le temps je crois pas
du tout que ce soit la tante des
français mais on veut
être
engagée
connaissez la différence entre impliqué
est engagé c'est assez facile
dans les oeufs au bacon
la poule
est impliqué mais le cochon est engagé
et bien
cette idée fondamentale
que nous sommes comme père de famille
comme citoyens engagés par les décisions
qu'ils prennent
c'est au tréfonds moins de l'âme
française
et c'est au tréfonds de l'âme française
encore davantage au 21ème siècle
pourquoi parce que 21e siècle c'est le
siècle d'internet
etc internet g1 développement sur sade
dans le livre c'est à la fois un poison
est l'antidote du poison
c'est un poison pourquoi hausse est un
poison parce que
ça va tellement vite
ça brasse tellement d'informations
ça distrait l'attention tout le temps
1 fait un une explosion une rumeur
chasse l'autre la tension a jamais le
temps de se fixer
et ça empêche évidemment la réflexion
s'empêche de s'arrêter une minute pour
réfléchir mais c'est en même temps
d'antidote parce que quinze ans après
vous pouvez revenir et le type qui a dit
ya quinze ans le contraire de ce qu'il
dit aujourd'hui vous le projeter pour sa
plus grande honte
puis vous pouvez vérifier la généalogie
de quelque chose qu'on vous apporte et
puis il ya des informations qui sont
pour la plupart d'entre elles fondées
moi je suis un
grand admirateur de wikipédia je
considère que wikipédia est une
révolution dans l'histoire de l'humanité
parce que bien sûr il ya des bêtises
quelquefois mais dans
999 sur 1000 des informations qui sont
présentes
aujourd'hui et ça sera encore plus vrai
dans cinq ans pour l'essentiel
il ya de la science
de la connaissance des choses qui sont
infiniment plus
détaillée que ne l'était
l'universalisme autrefois
et tous les jours s'est nourrie et ses
bénévoles
je trouve ça enfin quand on réfléchit
ce cette idée que
gratuitement
gratis pro deo comme on disait autrefois
en francs latin
comme on dit le franglais main réinvente
le franc lapin c'est quand même quelque
chose de fascinant
donc au temps d'internet
où tout le monde à l'information en
direct vous ne pouvez pas prétendre que
les gens n'ont pas voix au chapitre qui
les concernent
et pour une troisième raison
c'est que ces dirigeants qui prétendent
à la science à la connaissance à
l'initiation 1 à savoir à la technique
de tous les grands
dans les résultats ils sont nuls
et si vous ajoutez ces trois choses
france exigences de s'occuper de ses
affaires
21e siècle internet
échec des initiés
alors vous avez le
le système comme on dit
qui va vous conduire à l'exigence
démocratique telle que je la traite dans
cette affaire là donc il n'y a pas de
réforme possible s'il ya pas un contrat
de vérité c'est-à-dire de réel avec les
peuples et les peuples ont l'exigence de
s'occuper de leurs affaires
alors vous voyez que vous êtes dans le
constat des causes qui ont conduit la
france en tout cas la france à la
situation où elle se trouve pourquoi
étape supplémentaire
dans la cause
je voudrais traité de la cause de la
cause
je voudrais remontée l'enchaînement des
causes
je pense qu'il n'y a dans cette affaire
rien qui soit dû au hasard
alors on me dit mais monsieur c'est
parce que les politiques ne sont pas
courageux certes je crois pas du tout
que les politiques de nos voisins sont
plus courageux que les nôtres
même quelquefois moins
on me dit mais
le le pouvoir non je pense qu'il ya une
réalité et qui est comme toujours dans
les institutions
nous avons alors je reprends un refrain
que le général de gaulle a
sifflé sur la vie politique française
pendant dix ans il disait sous la ivème
parce que tous ses copains venaient le
voir pour participer au pouvoir pour
obtenir de lui la bénédiction
pour ne pas respecter ses orientations
quand les gens font un choix qui ne
correspond pas à la loyauté
qui on aurait pu attendre d'eux ils ont
très souvent besoin qu'on leur donne
l'absolution
très souvent besoin
bon alors il allait voir le général de
l'aude ils disaient mais félix gaillard
c'est un mec vachement bien
et probablement les dites
et de vous lisez écoutez dans ces
institutions de l'adie pour ces deux
gaillards en particulier dans ces
institutions là celle de la quatrième
vous aurez beau mettre les hommes
politiques les plus valeureux que vous
trouverez ils échoueront à coup sûr
alors qu'est ce qu'il ya dans nos
institutions qui selon moi fait où il ya
une chose très simple c'est que
à toute séquence électorale
présidentielle législatives il ya une
chose qui se joue c'est tout ou rien
vous gagnez vous avez tous le pouvoir
sans contre-pouvoir vous perdez vous
n'avez rien quand vous êtes le principal
parti de l'opposition et quand vous êtes
indépendant et que vous refusez la
soumission alors ou à l'autre alors vous
n'avez même pas de représentation
je vais additionner des voix qui n'ont
rien à voir entre elles et qui même son
désaccord profond entre elles mais
extrême droite
extrême gauche et nous
lors des trois dernières élections
présidentielles ça a fait 40 % à chaque
élection alors différemment à d'indiens
fin c'est nous qui avions 20 l'avant
dernière fois cette fois ci c'est marine
le pen qui avait 20 mai enfin 40% chaque
fois
marine le pen à peu près 20 mélenchon à
peu près 10 nous à peu près 10
penser que 40% des voix ont moins de 1%
de représentation
ça pose quand même une question parce
que ceux qui ont fait
chacun 25% au premier tour eux ils ont
toute la représentation des centaines de
sièges
est alors suivez le raisonnement que je
développe dans ce livre quand la
question c'est tout ou rien
que c'est à d'appareils politiques
il dit bah écoute coco 1 on va d'abord
s'occuper de gagner on verra ce qu'on
fait après
autrement dit il il ya dans ces
institutions
l'obligation ou la fatalité
de
du mieux-disant de la victoire du mieux
disant démagogique
je cite une phrase absolument véridique
de jacques chirac en 95 quand il était
dans les shows face à balladur
et il a dit au petit nombre de ceux qui
l'entouraient n'était plus qu'un petit
nombre passe que je ne sais pas pourquoi
les sondages en politiques organisent la
transhumance
il ya de vastes déménagement de
population parlementaire vers celui qui
est couronné provisoirement par les
sandales donc il avait plus personne
autour de lui
il les a réunis il leur a dit écoutez
bien
je vous étonnerez parma démagogie
il parlait pourtant des experts
dire des types qui est ben ça n'a pas
manqué
intéressantes sur des thèmes
intéressants mais
trois mois après il a fallu changer
françois hollande je parle de la
dernière élection car non
les chiffres de la croissance
françois hollande dit
nous aurons 2013 une croissance de 1,7
nicolas sarkozy dit mais nous aurons une
croissance de 2%
en à 0
bon moi j'étais pas à 0 cependant je
disais vos chiffres ne sont pas sérieux
évidemment quand il s'agit de tout rien
vont multiplier les promesses puis vous
dites après on verra trouvera bien se
passera des choses
ce qui compte c'est la phrase fétiche en
politique c'est le rapport de force et
bien moi je trouve que une fois qu'on a
compris ça alors on comprend que le mal
est dans la manière dont nous sommes
organisés regardez en italie c'est pas
parfait la démocratie italienne mais
monti il a perdu bon il a fait 10 %
c'est le tarif quand vous dites des
choses sérieuses vous verrez dans
quelques mois où en sera le thème
il a fait 10 % il a 50 sièges
quand vous avez 50 sièges vous pouvez
défendre une opposition au travers du
temps donc vous pouvez être courageux
j'ai expliqué à hollande 10 fois que et
avant à sarkozy que fraudeurs
n'avait pu faire agenda 2010 le grand
programme de réformes
que pour une raison c'est qu'ils avaient
un mode de scrutin qui garantisse est
que même dans l'impopularité son parti
ces représentants principaux seraient
sauvés
mais quand effectivement le risque est
d'être effacées de l'art d'oise
simplement parce que vous défendez une
position courageuse face au franc alors
vous étonnez pas que le courage sans ail
que le courage se dissolvent et
disparaissent donc nous avons une
responsabilité dans cette affaire voilà
la thèse initiale du livre alors après
il ya une question
qui est pour moi une question
existentielle
qui est tout simple
est ce que la politique ça consiste à
gagner les élections ou est ce que la
politique ça consiste à défendre devant
le peuple ou avec le peuple ce qui est
l'essentiel de son avenir
pas une question facile
alors je raconte dans le livre une
histoire formidable pour moi
on est en novembre
il ya un débat à la chambre des communes
novembre 36 jean pierre rioux vous
expliquera c'est la déclaration de lax
rome berlin
c'est à dire que tout d'un coup
on voit la guerre déployer ses ailes
noires
et la grande bretagne
n'a pas été préparé à se défendre
c'est le combat de churchill
depuis des années il est tout seul il
est l'homme politique le plus détesté de
grande bretagne
parce que la droite l'accuse d'être
passé à gauche et la gauche l'accusent
d'être restée à droite
voyez ce que je veux dire et donc
toute ressemblance
enfin quelquefois ça me fait rire
détesté par tout le monde mais il a eu
un combat il a dit ouvrez les yeux il
faut qu'on s'arme parce que la guerre
arrive alors ce jour là ils interpellent
baldwin c'est le chef du gouvernement
conservateur
gg très longtemps vous pensez
des choses assez sévère de baldwin pour
la raison que je vais expliquer depuis
j'ai découvert qu'il était le cousin
germain d'un ami à moi qui s'appelle
rudyard kipling qui est qui est un grand
enfin pour moi un admirable romancier
britannique anglais
les mères étaient soeurs alors ça me l'a
rendu plus sympathiques les les amis de
mes amis les cousins de mes amis sont
mes amis bon en tout cas un peu moins
mais
est il lui dit mais enfin vous saviez
tout vous pouvez pas dire que vous
découvrez la situation comment ça se
fait que vous n'ayez pas dit au peuple
britannique ce qui fallait faire pour
s'armer et alors il ya une réponse que
j'ai traduite dans le livre je cherchais
le débat qui est formidable
baldwin lui dit monsieur churchill je
vais vous répondre avec ce sont les
termes même une effroyable
sincérité
et le fait qu'ils emploient l'adjectif
effroyable
pour l'explication de
du fait qu'ils n'avaient pas ouvert les
yeux du peuple et quand même un aveu
il dit c'était en 34 il y avait des
élections j'étais le chef d'un grand
parti l'angleterre
était plus pacifistes à cette époque
qu'elle ne l'a jamais été dans son
histoire
et si j'avais dit au peuple britannique
qu'il fallait qu'on s'arme je ne vois
pas de chemins plus certains qui me
conduit à la défaite alors j'ai choisi
la victoire électorale
m ceci est la question même
que
un citoyen je dis même pas un homme
politique
ni un homme d'état est en tout cas ça
fait la différence entre les hommes
politiques et les hommes d'état cherche
il était un homme d'état van ryn était
un homme politique
la différence dis moi ce que tu choisis
si tu choisis l'intérêt électoral je
comprends bien que ça a des avantages
mais tu es un homme politique si tu
choisis
dans les moments difficiles de
l'histoire de ne pas arrêter à l'intérêt
et les électorale mais de défendre
l'intérêt
de ton pays dans l'histoire et dans sa
survie alors tu es peut-être non pas un
homme d'état mais un vrai citoyen
quelqu'un qui a ses responsabilités
moi je suis persuadé que la terre'
électorale doit passer av après la
question fondamentale de la survie du
pays et nous en sommes là vous avez vu
de scrutin dans l'oise dimanche
j'ai piqué un des fous rires les plus
spontané de ma vie
le dénommé mancelle haute figure
s'il en fut
fait au deuxième tour contre le front
national
alors que le ps a appelé à voter pour
lui
il fait 51 il est élu par le bo des
cheveux
normalement serait du trouble et l'ump
est bien le communiqué de l'ump croyez
le si vous voulez c'est
un
désaveu brutal pour françois hollande
ça c'est des hommes politiques
ils voient pas l'essentiel ils voient
pas le feu qui a dans le pays il voit
même pas qu'ils ont le feu à leur veste
et au bas de leur pantalon
il désigne l'autre l'adversaire sans
s'interroger un quart de seconde sur ce
qui se passe moi je pense qu'on est dans
un moment extrêmement
graves de la vie du pays
alors je voudrais aller juste un peu
plus loin parce qu'à une partie un peu
plus philosophique on va dire enfin c
est criant en france est
familiale
c'est que l'essence de la démocratie et
je cite en effet marc sangnier qui est
une référence pour moi et pour jacques
delors est pour beaucoup dans cette
salle il dit la démocratie et
l'organisation sociale qui porte à son
plus haut la conscience et la
responsabilité des citoyens et pour moi
c'est le plus profond de la démocratie
parce que ça veut dire que au lieu
d'avoir un peuple de soumis qui obéit
même s'il a le droit tous les quatre ans
de choisir
celui qui va le
cornac et
le diriger y compris contre son gré
c'est tout autre chose
conscients et responsables
ce que ça veut dire qu'il est un
partenaire dans le grand débat du pays
est selon moi la démocratie c'est
exactement ça et comme vous voyez en
france on en met assez loin alors ces
débats c'est pas la peine de rappeler il
ya eu de grandes figures pour les
illustrer ya donc un chapitre sur madame
france / bar sur de gaulle à sa manière
qui parfois sur l'affairé algérienne a
été
ambigu dans sa manière de faire les
choses et ça a été tragique pour
beaucoup de français et de harkis et
devant c'est pas rien mais qui cependant
a essayé chaque fois de prendre le débat
à la hauteur qu'il fallait mais cette
ambiguïté tête ils pouvaient pas faire
autrement je dis ça dans le livre mais
cette ambiguïté évidemment elle a été
cruellement ressentie par les uns et par
les autres par un bord et par l'autre
parce qu'ils étaient de l'autre côté
parce qu'ils
ont été obligés de d'abandonner ce qu'il
ressentait comme leur patrie leur terme
tout ça était d'une cruauté comme
histoire
et donc mais cependant il était à la
hauteur du débat tout un chapitre sur ce
point
j'avais une idée qui était intéressante
puisque j'ai perdu leader encore de
route et donc
oui
c'est une idée qui se rattache à une des
plus grandes questions philosophiques
pour moi de
de la politique
il y avait un monsieur qui s'appelait
machiavel
rien de grave
mais sans plus
c'est formidable ça prouve qu'ils n'ont
pas tous achetés et donc
je vais avoir du travail donc il faut
aller vite c'est ça que vous me dites
non mais ça va on a quelques minutes
mais j'ai presque fini
c'est une des plus grandes questions
philosophiques de la politique il ya un
monsieur qui s'appelait machiavel qui
sert de référence à des tas de gens et
qui prétendaient que la fin justifie les
moyens
j'ai pas tout à fait sûr qu'il ait dit
cela si on fouille dans l'oeuvre enfin
il demeure qu on lui prête la fin
justifie les moyens et vous avez des
désarmé de type qui vous disent la fin
justifie les moyens et moi je suis
ami dans l'histoire avec
quelqu'un qui s'appelle dandy qui a
guidé mes premiers pas dans l'engagement
politique quand j'étais très jeune quand
j'avais 17 ans
en tout cas ses oeuvres et ses disciples
et gandhi 10 à autre chose il disait la
fin
est dans les moyens comme l'arbre est
dans la grève
pour moi sa coupe la vie politique en
deux
le vrai clivage de la politique c'est
pas entre droite et gauche
gérard grumberg qu'on a reçu ici vient
de faire un papier dans commentaire pour
expliquer que c'était plus entre droite
et gauche lui donne vrai clivage c'est
entre europe et nation
moi je pense que le vrai clivage c'est
entre ceux qui pensent que la fin
justifie les moyens et ceux qui pensent
que la fin est dans les moyens comme
l'arbre est dans la grève que c'est la
même chose si tu acceptes de truander au
bout du chemin le peuple où la situation
du pays en sera détériorer s'améliorera
pas en démocratie en tout cas
naturellement je reviens sur l'élection
présidentielle de 2012
avec
l'explication du choix qui a été le mien
pas le vôtre pour un grand nombre
d'entre vous j'ai pris bien soin de
faire la différence même si elle n'est
pas très entendus
et au fond ce choix il revient à une
question simple
j'étais entré dans cette campagne
présidentielle d'abord pour dire ce que
je croyais nécessaire du réel et de la
vérité à mettre au coeur
des cinq années qui venait et
deuxièmement quand je me suis aperçu
que le le scrutin s'organisait autour
d'un double refus
ce qui ne voulait pas de sarkozy allait
voter hollande est ce qui l est ne
voulait pas de hollande aller voter
sarkozy que c'était une
cristallisation de deux refus c'est pas
avec deux refus qu'on fait une adhésion
mais c'est ça qui s'est produit alors
j'étais décidé à choisir au deuxième
tour pour plein de raisons mais l'une
d'entre elles est encore mon idée du
centre c'est que ça n'est pas un centre
assis entre deux chaises et qu'il est
capable et c'est pas un centre mou
c'est au contraire un dépassement et
puis une prise de risque et puis qu'on
nous entende quand on parle même si on
n'est pas d'accord avec vous je
dites lui dites lui que vous êtes avec
moi
si jamais il veut pas vous croire vous
me le passé
bas
et alors j'étais décidé à
la sorte à choisir a à assumer
et j'étais absolument sans idées
préconçues
parce que j'étais en désaccord violent
avec la politique économique de rolande
et je les dis j'ai dit qu'elle était
insoutenable
chaque jour qui passe et j'étais en
désaccord avec la pratique du pouvoir de
nicolas sarkozy alors qu'est-ce qui m'a
entraîné
et peut-être un certain nombre d'entre
vous me l'ont ils reprochaient gelé
entendu assez souvent peut-être vous
aussi
c'est très simple c'est que nicolas
sarkozy a choisi
comme thème principal de sa campagne
électorale
de
faire flamber
l'exaspération entre français
il ya 10 2 il a dit sa première
déclaration je ferai deux référentes
l'heure sur les chômeurs l'autre sur les
immigrés
et c'est assez simple à traduire c'est
par référendum sur les chômeurs et sur
les imiter c'est un référendum qui
permettront aux gens de se lâcher contre
ces deux figures de de l'inquiétude ou
du trouble ou de fixation des sentiments
qui est le chemin l'immigré mais ça
s'est pas arrêté là parce que après
enfin vous avez entendu quoi c'est pas
la peine que je que je raconte
l'histoire s'était constamment ça ce que
d'appeler la stratégie buisson mais pour
moi les conseillers ça n'existe pas
parce que les hommes politiques
choisissent leurs conseillers et les
choisissent généralement parce qu'ils
vont dans le sens de ce qui l'attend
c'est sur ce point là j'ai dit une
phrase on avait le choix entre la
division et l'illusion un pays peut
revenir de ses illusions il revient pas
de cette division en crise
où je sais très bien que c'est
électoralement puissant d'ailleurs
sarkozy a fait 49 48 et quelques c'est
pas rien c'est une formidable
performance électorale
oui entier on dit toujours ça
je les dis moi c'est souvent
je ne peux pas lui reprocher de jeu ne
peut pas lui reprocher de dire ça en
vérité je crois que quelle que soit la
longueur de la campagne la durée de la
campagne les forces politiques
s'agrègent autour de ce qu'ils aiment te
voilà même si la campagne ne dure que
cinq semaines comme ça arrive quand un
président de la république démissionne
ou disparaît en cours de mandat il se
passe la même chose
si je veux me référer à mon ancien
métier que la pièce soit en un acte ou
en cinq actes il se passe la même chose
interne de la caisse parce que je crois
et je peux me tromper vous avez le droit
d'être en désaccord avec moi surtout
donc voilà la raison pour laquelle j'ai
fait ce choix j'ai dit dans cette pièce
le soir de cette annonce qui a fait
quelques vagues y compris dans ma vie
j'ai dit deux j'ai regardé le clip de
campagne dans le clip de campagne avait
à banos douanes
écrit en français et en arabe
c'est pas tout à fait par hasard faut
aller le chercher le panneau douanes
écrit en français et en arabe
fall est précisément le chercher au
maroc
je sais très bien ce que ça veut dire et
vous aussi vous savez très bien ce que
ça veut dire
puisque c'est l exaltation de la
frontière
comprenez bien ce que je dis moi je suis
pas quelqu'un qui dit que l'immigration
c'est facile je ne suis pas quelqu'un
qui dit que l'intégration marche je suis
quelqu'un qui dit précisément
jean-pierre que le rôle
d'un président de la république le rôle
d'un chef d'état
qui connaît parfaitement ses fractures
c'est
d'empêcher que ces fractures de sa grave
elle existe je sais exactement tout sur
cette affaire là je viens
de ce qu'on appelle le peuple je viens
de loin d'un pays dans lequel mes amis
sont des chemins de les amis d'enfance
et mes voisins des chômeurs des smicards
des c'est très bien les sentiments qui
existe mais
il en est d'un président de la
république comme d'un chef de famille il
sait très bien le chef de famille que
quand ils sont assis à la table tous
ensemble les belles soeurs déteste les
belles filles détestent leur belle-mère
que les belles soeurs s'entendent pas
entre elles que il ya une cousine qui la
veille a dit du mal de vous
je raconte votre histoire hein
la mienne est la vôtre est bien le père
de famille alors on pourrait dire la mer
aussi je fais pas de sexisme dans cette
affaire
le chef de famille ou le responsable de
famille ils ferment les yeux sur ces
choses et il essaie de les apaiser
plutôt que de les exciter sinon la
famille explose et en temps de crise
c'est plus dur qu'à aucun autre moment
7 c ces analogies là elles sont plus
parlantes qu'on ne croit parce que moi
je pense que un peuple c'est une unité
surtout quand ça va mal dans les temps
de guerre comme vous le disiez mais pour
moi nous sommes dans un temps de guerre
alors c'est pas une guerre avec des
bombes
mais quand vous avez cinq millions de
chômeurs
ce soit encore 26500 de plus
quand vous avez c'est les familles de
260 familles nouvelles dans les 100
départements français
et les parents se regardent plus pareil
quand ils trouvent plus de boulot et les
enfants regardent plus les parents
paraît quand ils trouvent plus de boulot
et quand les jeunes trouvent pas de
boulot les parents sont malheureux et
tout ça ça fait une espèce de tache mais
c'est comme une guerre et celle des
guerres affreuse parce que nous n'avons
pas mobilisé les armes qui étaient les
nôtres
et donc on est dans un roman c'était une
partie de mes choix dans lequel j'ai
pensé et je continue à penser que la
gauche qui avait été depuis 30 ans le
principal obstacle aux réformes
nécessaires allez devoir s'en faire le
pédagogue au s'est pas fait
ces esquisses et
mais en prenant la précaution de
toujours équilibré le plateau de la
balance et de mettre une pincée
sur le plateau réformiste et une pincée
sur le plateau d'extrême gauche
et j'ai pensé je je suis transparent
avec vous que la nécessité d'une
politique économique réformiste et
courageuse allait faire exploser la
gauche contre nature puisque c'est une
contre nature alliance de la gauche et
franchement je crois que c'est en train
de se faire quand mélenchon
au micro
après avoir réfléchi pendant 48 heures
traite moscovici de salopards
les mots en politique ont du sens n'est
ce pas c'est pas par hasard c'est des
choses profondes
quand le leader
de la faction la plus importante de la
gauche en dehors du ps traite le
ministre de l'économie du gouvernement
socialiste de salopards dix mois après
l'élection de cette majorité je vous dis
qu'il se passe quelque chose
qui n'est pas anodin qui est pas
secondaire qui est pas des querelles de
cour de récréation c'est une chose
profonde idéologique de fond parce que
comme je les dis le jour où j'ai fait ce
choix la politique qu'il va falloir
suivre et le contraire de ce que le ps
appelait hier devant le pays pendant 30
ans
alors je dis pas que ça va être facile
mes mains mon idée c'est que pour une
politique réformiste il va falloir un
une courant réformiste puissant et donc
un changement des institutions
alors maintenant qu'est-ce que c'est la
politique réformiste et jal aurait fini
avec le livre vous aurez plus besoin de
le lire
d'ailleurs j'insiste pas pour que vous
le lisiez j'insiste pour que vous
l'achetiez
je vais les faire bon à une minute par
livre ça fait qu'une petite heure c'est
par quoi bon
il ya trois choses à faire pour moi la
première de ces choses c'est
mettre en place la politique d'urgence
dont le pays a besoin qu'est ce que
j'appelle politique d'urgence au c'est
très simple si on reprend l'idée que
nous sommes en guerre qui y est dans la
tranchée en première ligne
il ya tous ceux qui signent des contrats
de travail
toutes les entreprises petites moyennes
grandes tous les artisans tous les
commerçants tous les petites entreprises
tous les
ja les innovateurs il ya les chercheurs
il ya voilà c'est eux qui sont premiers
ceux qui défendent
l'essentiel pour le pays c'est à dire
les ressources et les emplois
qu'est ce qu'on demande aux jeux
demandent pas des choses compliquées je
demande qu'on arrête de leur gâcher la
vie
et on leur gâche la vie tous les jours
j'ai apporté l'autre soir sur le plateau
de ruquier
le code du travail je voulais dit déjà
ce que je sais plus où j'en suis
le code du travail suisse
je vous ai dit ce qu'il en était du
chômage en suisse à dire disparu
le code du travail suisse il fait
120 pages petit comme ça et le code du
travail français y pèse 2 kg et il ya
deux mille neuf cents pages
et vous vous dites
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
des choses évidentes pour chacun d'entre
vous le plombier
dont la femme fait la comptabilité et
les contrats de travail et s'occupe des
relations avec l'urssaf il ne peut pas
comprendre ce dont il s'agit c'est trop
compliqué labyrinthique alors ça fait la
fortune pardon si on a ici je veux rien
dire de mal des avocats en droit social
des drh des grandes entreprises qui ont
des centaines de personnes pour que tout
ça serve à l'entreprise et
des directions
correspondante des grands syndicats
mais de ceux qui créent du travail ça
les empoisonnent et on peut aller plus
loin dans tout ça je pense que on doit
réfléchir au seuil
10 50 qui font que nous connaissons tous
des entreprises qui s'oblige à rester en
deçà des seuils
bon entend tout va bien ça va au temps
où tout va mal ça se discute de même que
je pense que la question du temps de
travail mérite d'être discutée et un peu
ouverte de même que la question des
normes
perpétuellement aggravée est une
question qui est paralysant tout à
l'heure un ami me racontait il à un
couvreur
qui était chez lui vendredi soir il
rentre et il trouve le couvreur en train
de pleurer il dit qu'est ce qui se passe
il dit belge peut pas continuer chez ge
est arrêté et dit pourquoi mais écoutez
je n'ai plus le droit de monter sur les
toits pour changer une ardoise avec une
échelle
faut que je mette un échafaudage
bon je dis pas que ça parte d'un mauvais
sentiments mais vous comprenez ce que je
veux dire c'est que ça devient si lourd
que dans un moment difficile
une petite entreprise et ne peut plus
faire face à toutes ces choses alors il
ya ceux qui s'en fichent et qui passe au
delà mais
dans un pays où c'est la sève du pays
qui est en jeu
le le sens du pays qui est en jeu on
devrait faciliter par tous les moyens le
travail de ceux qui sont en première
ligne je demande pas autre chose que ça
arrêtez de les embêter
et essayer de les soutenir de leur
donner une fiscalité raisonnable
on vient découvrir
découvrir en tout cas beaucoup de
lecteurs ont découvert à propos de
chypre que nos avions l'impôt sur les
sociétés le plus lourd de toute l'europe
ça mérite une réflexion
de même que faudrait avoir je vais dire
des choses obscène
moi je trouve que quelqu'un qui crée de
l'emploi et des ressources il a le droit
de bien gagner sa vie
vous savez ce que j'avais dit leur ce
que hollande a annoncé les 75% j'avais
dit le d'économe être fonctionne à plein
tube
et on s'est aperçus après y compris au
conseil constitutionnel
tardivement mais mais le pire c'est
qu'il savait très bien hollande a eu un
débat avec thomas piketty sur mediapart
que je vous invite à regarder dans
lequel ils expliquent urbi et orbi
qu'une fiscalité excessive
c'est un
très mauvais signal pour le pays
épique et y proposer 60 bon et il fait
le contraire vous voyez bien qu'il ya
devant nous des choses qui permettrait
aux gens d'être assuré que le soutien du
pays leur est apportée
pour moi tout ça c'est la politique
d'urgence qu'il faut mettre en oeuvre
vous voyez bien ce que je suis en train
de dire
il ya eu une évolution aussi dans le
dans les choix que j'ai défendue devant
les français j'ai commencé il ya douze
ans en disant attention la dette va vous
exploser à la figure
attention les déficits vont nous
conduire dans le mur et j'ai proposé
qu'on ait une meilleure gestion de
l'argent public et que donc on fasse les
rééquilibrages nécessaires
dans la situation actuelle je vais plus
loin jeudi la question principale elle
n'est pas des copains et des ressources
parce que si on continue sur le chemin
de l'effondrement des ressources les
coupes ne suffiront jamais
prenez une serpette prenez une faux
prenez une hache prenez une tronçonneuse
je peux peut-être aller plus loin ça ne
suffira jamais puisque vous n'avez pas
les ressources nécessaires
et donc la mise en oeuvre d'une
politique pro ressources et pro emploi
c'est la politique d'urgence qui a à
construire deuxième politique il faut
s'occuper de l'état qui est devenu
autobloquant
alors il ya des élus parmi vous
même les décisions que l'état prend pour
lui même il réussit pas les appliquer
vous revenez six mois après huit mois
après c'est des textes jargonneux
incompréhensible qu'un jeu me faire
encore des amis on vient de voter une
loi qui parait-il s'appelle de
refondation de l'école je vous invite à
la lire c'est illisible
même pour un ancien ministre de
l'éducation nationale
je vous jure la loi elle fait 80 pages
avec 100 pages d'alex
ou quoi ixellois de refondation fin et
l'essentiel de la loi c'est que ça
supprime les cycles
autour desquels on avait organisé
l'enseignement primaire et le collège
et l'option possible pour des élèves qui
ne veulent plus aller à l'école d'avoir
une initiation à l'apprentissage 14 ans
supprimés
rahoui remplacé par rien
si encore on avait dit ça sera plus
organisé en cycle mais on va l'organiser
en d'une manière des pas du tout on dit
on supprime les cycles
et on dira par décret le nouveau système
comme adapte on appelle ça une loi pour
moi c'est pas une loi bon j'en veux pas
à peillon je vais j'ai plutôt de la
sympathie
pour lui mais vous voyez bien tout ce
système que personne ne peut comprendre
excusez moi de le dire le système des
collectivités locales personne ne peut
rien y comprendre la commune la
communauté de communes le département la
région avec des élus différent pour les
deux dd c'est incompréhensible
et alors la loi qu'on vient de voter
pour le fait qu' on aura désormais sur
le bulletin des élections cantonales au
scrutin majoritaire à deux tours quatre
noms un homme une femme une femme un
homme
pour peut-être c'est bien pour
quelques-uns qui considère que le rôle
principal des élus c'est d'être des
animateurs pas du tout les pour moi je
dis on doit fusionner les départements
et les régions ça fait le même travail
alors les conseillers régionaux maïs
quand je dis ça est les conseillers
généraux quelquefois aussi mais bon
c'est le même travail j'ai été président
de département pendant dix ans
le département et la région ont tous les
deux la responsabilité de stratégie de
développement local
la même chose le périmètre change mais
je connais beaucoup de départements qui
ont contribué à construire des
universités
le mien a construit une autoroute
chacun s'occupe d'économie en mettant en
place des zones industrielles
artisanales
les uns ont les collèges et les autres
les lycées mais excusez moi c'est la
même chose
s'occuper de l'équipement matériel des
collèges et des lycées de les construire
maintenant il y en a beaucoup de
construire ou de l'organisation des
cantines tout ça c'est la même chose
c'est le même travail
pourquoi est-ce qu'on fait pas de faire
sa part les mêmes élus ils peuvent
délibérer sur place quand c'est pour le
département
chérir de la région qu'on sait pour la
région mais c'est le même travail
et puis
communes et communautés de communes et
maintenant métropole enfin tout ça
devient
extraordinairement difficile à
comprendre je suis si j'ose dire vous
allez il captait pas de riz je suis
comme napoléon je suis pour la simplifie
la simplicité pour que ce soit
compréhensible
l'état et les collectivités locales
c'est la deuxième chose à faire pour
sortir de ces blocages ah non monsieur
c'est pas ici c'est ici ces deux
départements c'est à la région qu'il
faut aller à pas du tout c'est à la
communauté de communes et on vous
renvoie bon j'ai raconté l'autre soir
elle
les commandites et les centres d'appels
de sdf d'orange et de toutes ces choses
là bon
c'est un monde très cruel c'est un monde
pour l'effort
pour ceux qui ont des relations
pour ceux qui parle bien français
pour ceux qui voient bien pour ceux qui
peuvent se faire entendre et qui au bout
de 23 minutes d'attendre téléphone quand
le garçon qui est en face les entends il
sait que faut parler
poliment
c'est vrai on entende l'autorité de
temps la voix des gens
et si c'est quelqu'un qui ne sait pas
s'exprimer
l'équipe à ce qu'ils étaient d'hervé
parle un peu plus haut on raccroche et
tu repars pour 23 minutes de plus
c'est vrai ce que je raconte ou pas
- je pense qu'il faut
c'est un monde qui est impossible à
vivre pour
50% de la population
eh bien on devrait organiser pour cela
précisément d'abord pour cela il ya une
troisième chose à faire et je finis là
dessus parce que c'est un grand sujet
c'est il faut répondre au drame européen
ce qui vient de se passer à chypre
pour moi c'est un drame alors tout le
monde applaudit il paraît que tout le
monde est content de l'accord
moi je suis inquiet je vais vous dire
pourquoi de manière très simple
je suis pas du tout triste qu'on enlève
aux oligarques russes et à quelques
milliardaires égard et
l'argent qu'ils ont dans la lie qui
banques parce que la corse et
la lie qui banque est mise en faillite
c'est la deuxième banque de chypre tous
ceux qui ont des dépôts au delà de cent
mille euros
100 % de perte
et ceux qui avaient des dépôts dans la
première banque de chypre bank of cyprus
cela c'est 30 % de chute
alors franchement
ça ne me troublerait pas si ça veut dire
une chose extrêmement précise c'est que
désormais chaque fois qu'un pays sera en
difficulté au premier bruit de ses
difficultés tous les types qui ont des
dépôts supérieurs à 100 milles devant
les retirer
et vous êtes ou alors je me trompe alors
cheminots c'est possible que je sois
idiot mais moi je crois que l'économie
est systémique c'est un système vous
appuyez sur le bouton à ça entraîne
quelque chose qui bouge
ab qui bouge assez et puis a précédé qui
réagit et eux il ya des accélérations
comme ça c'est ça un système je pense
que c'est une décision
tient attendait les premiers bruits de
crise bancaire en espagne
les revenez me voir ou en italie
mais revenez me voir je pense que c'est
une décision pour quelques milliards
d'euros très imprudente
deuxièmement vous allez avoir à chiper
une crise sociale d'envergure
colossal parce que vous allez avoir
20 lille peut-être suppressions
d'emplois et mis au chômage
et puis pourquoi mais parce que les pme
vont plus pouvoir emprunter
on vient de mettre en place cette
personne s'en est aperçu ce qu'on a créé
à chypre c'est un euro non convertible
pendant une période qu'on sait pas un
euro non convertible c'est plus un euro
enfin c'est autre chose c'est à dire que
les types pourront pas acheter avec
cette heure-là
est à mon sens ça va entraîner des
licenciements assez nombreux le peuple
chypriote ne risquent de ne pas le
supporter risque donc de quitter l'euro
par un mouvement politique de remise en
cause le président il est élu depuis 1 -
là encore vérité en politique
1 - n'a pas dit le le quart de ce qu'ils
allaient faire ou de ce qu'on allait
l'obliger à faire quatrièmement et enfin
c'est très mauvais pour l'europe qu'elle
apparaisse
comme une trouille qu'à manille ont un
doute
je trouve que le mot treika
lui-même en soi
vous comprenez si l'europe c'est
le le
le
l'organisation d'une contrainte qui
risque de vous entraîner là où vous ne
voulez pas aller
les peuples vont dire non
et vous allez voir tous les mélenchon de
la création tout les le pen de la
création
menacer les français du même genre de
contraintes donc il va falloir que nous
soyons imaginatifs
convaincu éloquent
de bonnes soit pour montrer un autre
horizon européen dans les mois qui
viennent et singulièrement aux élections
européennes dans un an la charge qui
nous incombe est très importante parce
que et le ps et l'ump sont ficelés dans
cette affaire et nous nous avons
peut-être cette capacité là en tout cas
je le crois mais vous voyez bien faut
créer une autorité politique dans la
zone euro il faut que cette autorité
pourquoi faut créer d'autorité politique
c'est simple quand vous avez une monnaie
unique vous êtes obligés d'avoir une
autorité politique pour faire de
l'aménagement du territoire minimale
autrement les activités des ménages vers
les zones les plus attractives
et c'est l'organisation de désert à
l'intérieur du territoire ce qu'un pays
fait l'aménagement du territoire c'est
essayer de favoriser la vie là où ça va
pas et de freiner un tout petit peu là
où ça va trop vite et ça cède c'est une
autorité politique à condition que cette
autorité politique qu'elle soit
transparente
qu'on sache de quoi on parle et qui
décide
ce que pas un d'entre vous n'est capable
en dehors des grands spécialistes
présents ici de décrire et encore si on
faisait un approfondissement verrez
qu'il ya beaucoup de zones
d'incertitudes
qu'elle soit transparente parce que les
citoyens veulent savoir 2 2 de quoi leur
avenir va être fait ce sont des
décisions très importantes elles les
concernent
et moi je supporte pas même moins
d'apprendre le matin à 6 heures à la
radio quelque chose dont je sais que ça
va jouer un rôle très important pour
l'avenir et donc on a là la nécessité
d'une d'une
renaissance
européenne
avec une autorité intégrer politique
pour la zone euro en tout cas est une
démocratie européenne voilà j'en ai fini
parce que là on vient de traiter les
questions massive de l'avenir du pays
j'ai été infiniment trop long mais on va
faire un quart d'heure de questions
avant qu'on ne signe pour que vous
puissiez répondre alors on va se tenir à
la règle habituelle qui est cependant
que yann wehrling nous quitte sous les
déclarations d'affection de son
président
et
tu n'es pas très bien parce que je
m'ennuie quand tu es loin de moi et donc
on va faire alternance
masculin féminin
alors on va prendre six questions
j'ai été trop longs excusez moi mais bon
sur emprunté par le sujet pour voir à
tous pour soir monsieur bayrou alors
vous avez parlé de différent a créé pour
la refonte des institutions vous avez
parlé dans un premier temps des
décideurs économiques les décideurs
politiques de l'europe mais vous avez
pas parlé des citoyens et j'aimerais
savoir où vous placez les citoyens c'est
à dire nous dans cette volonté de
reconquête du pouvoir au début de votre
intervention vous allez parler de
l'allemagne et de l'italie
que ce journal magne avec le parti des
pirates ou en italie avec les parties de
l'est des griots c'est quand même
révolutionnaire qui vient de passer je
crois qu'on en fera plus jamais de la
politique de la même manière aujourd'hui
le parti de beppe grillo qui est le
deuxième parti d'italie premier le
premier rang c'est un parti qui n'avait
aucun siège c'est un parti qui se fait
exclusivement sur internet alors dans
votre volonté légitime et que je
soutiens de refonder institutions clés
nécessaires on vit sur des institutions
qui sont trop vieille et pas adapté au
monde moderne ou est-ce que vous
déplacer nous ici d'abord je n'ai parlé
que des citoyens pendant toute cette
intervention
un que des citoyens pendant toute cette
intervention parce que les citoyens
c'est nous alors je vais vous dire
quelque chose qui va vous faire de la
peine
c'est exactement la même chose que les
indignés en espagne
et peut-être d'autres voient dans
d'autres pays européens
derrière ça
pour moi il ya une impasse
beppe grillo eddy faut sortir de l'euro
faut donner un salaire minimum de 1000
euros par mois à chaque famille
italienne
et ainsi de suite
ces deux choses là sont
impossibles et vont déboucher sur un
grave accident
peut-être je me trompe j'attends de le
voir
est en tout cas en france
cela serait
insoutenable
bon on va voir si je me trompe il n'y a
que quelques jours à attendre pour
savoir s'il ya une majorité pour le
gouvernement
bersani
c'est à dire s'il ya un accord avec une
partie des membres du mouvement cinq
étoiles de grillons
s'il n'y a pas d'accord on va voir de
nouveaux nouvelles élections une impasse
terrible enfin on est dans une pour moi
une de ses manières des gares et les
citoyens en leur expliquant que c'est
très facile il suffit de virer les
gouvernants
n'y a pas de changement je veux dire il
n'y a pas de différence majeure avec
ceux qui disaient le changement
donc je sais bien que c'est pas agréable
à entendre mais pour moi berlusconi et
griots
c'est la même impasse camp berlusconi
dit je vais vous remboursez vos impôts
c'est avec ça qu'il a fait 26 pour cent
vingt je vais vous remboursez vos impôts
il a envoyé à toutes les familles
italiennes un bon
imprimé en disant si je suis élue lundi
matin vous allez à la poste avec second
et on vous rembourse ou des impôts
c'est une
escroquerie démocratique
alors ça fait des voix très bien mais ça
amènera le pays à une catastrophe voilà
ce que je crois donc je ne crois pas du
tout à beppe grillo de ce point de vue
là en revanche les dix j'ai commencé par
ça j'ai pas si vous étiez là au début la
revendication des citoyens d'avoir à
s'occuper de leurs affaires c'est une
revendication irrésistible est justifiée
mais ça doit se faire
peut-être nous le faisons ici après tout
hein chaque soir où nous discutons de
des grands problèmes du pays
je trouve que nous sommes dans une
démarche civique comme celle-là civique
ça veut dire que les citoyens sont
pleinement respectés voilà ce que je
crois mais je peux me tromper on va le
voir dans quelques semaines
surtout que j'ajoute que beppe grillo il
y a eu aussi des thèmes des thèmes très
très
déstabilisant sur l'immigration sur
compris quelquefois avec des relents là
c'est c'est ryad c'est la démagogie
prétendre qu'on peut donner 1000 euros
par mois toutes les familles
moi je suis je vous le dis c'est une
chose qui ne se produira pas
bon on va voir qui est le courage et je
préfère être ami avec mario monti
ou avec hôtel lee qui a dit dans ces
circonstances je me présente pas
avec mario monti qui a fait 10 % que
d'être
dans l'idée que le
ce mouvement-là va apporter une solution
aux problèmes de l'italie je crois
exactement le contraire mais nous seront
départagés par la réalité j'aimerais
qu'il y ait des solutions magiques n'y
en a pas et donc
je préfère défendre quelque chose qui
est rapport avec de la vérité en
politique féminin oui bon sens mais
c'est bayrou donc je vous entends pas
vous n'entendez pas ça y est ça y est
c'est bon donc je voulais revenir sur le
titre de votre livre de la vérité en
politique
donc apparemment enfin vous avez
expliqué que le citoyen vous souhaitiez
qu'il soit participatif
qu'il
qu'ils soient impliqués qui s'occupe de
ses affaires mais est ce que vous
pourriez est-ce que vous souhaitez aller
plus loin et a abordé la vérité en
philosophie c'est à dire qu'est ce qui
pourrait faire que le citoyen si vous
voulez soit encore plus participatif
vous avez parlé de la conscience
éveillée la conscience du citoyen est-ce
qu'on peut aussi penser à la notion de
bonheur est ce que tous à tous ces
thèmes là voulaient regroupe riez aussi
est ce que ce serait quelque chose
d'autre au delà où on se limite à la
vérité en politique
là je je suis absolument
respectueux de la frontière entre l'un
et l'autre
dès qu'on parle de bonheur en politique
ça tourne mal
les gens qui ont voulu faire le bonheur
des peuples
c'est des gens qui confondent deux
choses
l'une qui est l' équilibre d'une société
sa
capacité
à inventer produire des oeuvres
littéraires artistiques culturels
numériques que sais-je et
l'idée que chacun se fait de son
épanouissement personnel si vous
confondez l'un et l'autre ce qu'est le
totalitarisme
totalitarisme c'est les gens qui
décident que ils vont décider du bonheur
et bien cela - je m'en écarte avec
beaucoup beaucoup de
devaux de détermination
c'est un trop grand risque
comprenez que la mission
des responsables politiques c'est pas la
mission de faire le bonheur de chacun
des gens c'est impossible c'est chacun
qui doit faire son bonheur
eux ils se contentent de mettre des
cadres dans lequel dans lesquelles le
les femmes les hommes les familles les
communautés
pourront s'épanouir
et après eh bien ils sont laïques
c'est à dire que il se mêle pas de ce
genre de sujet voilà en tout cas la
vision qui est la mienne
masculine
attendez c'est c'est la petite labaki
dans soir a fait partie le micro je
voudrais rester sur le thème de la
philosophie il ya quelque chose qui
m'intéresse fortement
c'est que au delà du rôle de la bi
polaire et bobby polarisation j'ai
l'impression que l'existence même de
tout parti politique quel qu'il soit y
compris le modem est un obstacle à la
vérité en politique je fais référence à
un texte que vous connaissez sans doute
de simone veil avec un w voilà donc du
coup ma question c'est à vous à titre
personnel en tant que président d'un
parti comment vous assumer cette
contradiction est ce que vous la
ressentez comment vous l'assumez cette
contradiction et nous en tant que
citoyens comme on peut à la fois porter
vain essayé de porter la vérité en
politique sans tomber dans des jeux
partisans alors je je répète j'ai jamais
défendu l'idée que nous avions la vérité
qu'on allait la transmettre aux autres
j'ai défendu l'idée que là la vérité du
réel
la phrase que j'ai lu de hannah arendt
c'est à dire la vérité c'est ce qu'on ne
peut pas changer
et ça devrait être
les fondements les piliers du débat
politique alors la vision de simone veil
-le des partis politiques de simone veil
d' la philosophe
des partis politiques c'est une vision
oui certains moments sévère
justifier sans doute parce qu'un parti
politique c'est
le péché originel des partis politiques
celui que j'ai combattu toute ma vie
c'est le sectarisme je dis pas que j'ai
jamais été mois menace et d'attitudes de
ce genre parfois dans des élections sans
doute mais je j'ai combattu le
sectarisme toute ma vie c'est pour ça
que j'ai voulu faire un parti ouvert à
des alliances différentes
un parti qui ne se définissent pas par
un camp
est un parti qui accepte l'idée qu' il
pouvait avoir des partenaires même
qu'ils n'ont pas la même carte que lui
dans leur poche
alors ça correspond à quelque chose d'un
peu plus profond qui est que
l'autre n'est pas un ennemi
envoyée il ya des arrière plans
spirituel spiritualiste dans tout ça que
j'assume que j'accepte mais
philosophique l'autre n'est pas un
ennemi
c'est pas parce qu'il est différent
qu'il est un
événement et qu'est ce que ça dit le mot
centre que que j'ai on à situer notre
action ça dit que
la vérité ne se résume ne se résume en
fin de
la politique ne se résume pas à
l'affrontement de deux camps qui sont
forcément deux mensonges
et qu'il faut dépasser ça
bon donc
s'il peut exister un parti non sectaire
c'est ici qu'il existe
alors je dis pas que ce soit parfait je
dis pas que cette organisation était
impeccable tout autour tout au long du
temps parce que faire un parti nouveau
c'est très difficile comme l'ont montré
tous les partis nouveaux créés ces
dernières années
europe ecologie les verts
lisez ce que cohn bendit andy
bas
le nouveau parti anticapitaliste
nous rien n'est facile quand vous créez
un parti nouveau et j'en cite pas
d'autre par charité
chrétienne
et donc mais bon ce rien n'est facile
mais en tout cas
ayant inscrit dans son patrimoine
génétique
l'idée que le sectarisme et a repoussé
il ya que nous
c'est déjà pas mal
et je suis sûr que simone veil avec un w
si elle avait eu à choisir
un courant ou une sensibilité je suis
sûr que elle l'aurait fait en tout cas
elle a été la philosophe de mes 16 ans
et donc je ne l'oublierai jamais un
livre qui s'appelle par exemple
l'enracinement qui est un
mme admirable qui moi m'a fait découvrir
ce que la philosophie pouvait être
masculin ou féminin
féminin
attendez attendez en tout est enregistré
oui donc je voulais parler de l'europe
c'est les cinq dernières minutes comme
disait l'inspecteur comment il
s'appelait bourrel fallait vite juste
une question sur l'europe et sur la
pédagogie de l'europe quand vous
discutez dans différents cercles autour
de vous à l'étranger vous apercevez que
le plus grand mal c'est que l'europe on
ne la connaît pas on ignore toutes ses
institutions ses modes de fonctionnement
les parlementaires de strasbourg font un
travail remarquable
il est inconnu les partis politiques
dans chaque pays surtout en france ne le
mettent jamais en valeur bailly suivent
oui nan mais j'parle généralement à la
télévision et dans le journal voilà donc
c'est il faut qu'on arrive à faire une
vaste diffusion du travail qui a été
fait des progrès pour les effets sont
compliquées mais donner une vision
simple et surtout faire que pendant
cette campagne européenne
on ne se présente pas entre
franchouillard c'est à dire qu'on est
dans des débats un allemand un anglais
un espagnol un français oui peut-être
compte qu'on est con qu'on présente ces
gens il ya des anglais parlent français
ça existe il ya des allemands qui par
fabien français etc et donc on arrive à
un débat européen
présenté avec des tribunes pour que les
gens voient que c'est concret
madame
en une phrase vous dites on les connaît
pas c'est fait pour ça fait pour ça il
faut casser hélas
la manière dont sont organisés
ces institutions
elle hélas alors ça s'explique à
jean monnet
lorsqu'il a
défriché les premiers chemins on était
dans une période de germanophobie très
grande en france et réciproquement
symétriquement de francophobie sans
doute en allemagne
et en italie vous voyez ce qu'il en
était et donc il a choisi un chemin qui
était spontané chez lui on va monter ça
entre initiés
sans que on étale trop devant les
peuples parce qu'il leur jetterai
mais on en est resté là et selon ce que
je défends ça n'est plus acceptable au
21ème siècle
donc je suis pour que l'on soit
réformateur
refondateurs de l'europe et je crois
qu'on en a à la fois la capacité
l'inventivité on peut faire ça question
fait mieux masculine pardon
bonjour monsieur bayrou j'ai commencé à
lire votre livre est pour parler de la
vérité en politique va donner une
condition nécessaire dans un des
chapitres c'est que cette vérité
s'appuie sur des faits avérés
cela paraît assez évident mais en fait
je ne suis pas si sûre que ce soit aussi
évident que cela je pourrais citer des
exemples même en géographie
physique une ministre pensait que le
japon était dans l'hémisphère sud sans
vouloir être cruel où il y avait aussi à
venise l'agriculture qui savait pas ce
que c'était un hectare
en matière économique on a souvent
reproché remarquer si je faisais une
interro écrite sur ce que c'est un
hectare enfin bref
en matière économique dans la sphère
madoff on a souvent reproché aux
économistes mathématiciens de ne pas
avoir senti venir le vent et ne pas
avoir détecté que c'était impossible en
fait c'était faux il y avait deux
économistes mathématiciens qui avait
démontré
de manière rigoureuse que le système
madoff était impossible il avait
transmis leurs conclusions à la sec et
on n'a absolument pas tenu compte de
leur démonstration en fait on peut se
demander si quelque part
les idées reçues ne l'emportent pas
l'espoir un certain optimisme ne finit
pas pendant porter c'est à dire qu on a
envie de croire au père noël et si
quelque part et bien c'est fait avéré ne
sont pas aussi
je suis très très difficile à établir et
ça me fait penser que pour que l'homme
politique le décideur dise la vérité il
doit s'appuyer aussi sur des conseillers
sacrément solide et qui est lui présente
aussi
des éléments très objectif je pensais
alors
déconseillé suffisamment solides et qui
présente des éléments avérés ça doit
être dirigé vers les citoyens
l'homme politique je préfère qu'il est
lui-même des idées et des convictions et
du bon sens parce que je ne crois pas
que ce soit des sujets difficiles
deuxièmement vous dites c'est difficile
à établir les faits je ne demande pas
qu'on établisse tous les faits je
demande qu'on se mette d'accord sur
des éléments très peu nombreux et
indiscutable quand j'ai commencé à
dénoncer la croissance de la dette en
france seuil à
howie 2002 peut-être avant 99 puis on le
faisait déjà avec bar ça fait un bail
bon tout était dans l'arithmétique
c'est pas de la mathématique abstraite
de l'arithmétique
vous m'avez vous êtes souvent moqué de
moi parce que je disais que le calcul
mental
était une dispute
discipline
civique jeu persuadé que si les gens
avaient su ce qu'est un milliard
je suis persuadé qu'ils n'auraient pas
laissé faire
quand on a dépassé 1000 milliards il
aurait dit attention et se passe quelque
chose
autre exemple je suis persuadé que si
les gens avaient su
ce que représente 400 millions d'euros
lé affaire tapie n'aurait pas eu lieu
parce que
400 millions d'euros
ce sont des sommes
pyramidale
mais le calcul mental ayant disparu de
la formation élémentaires du citoyen
c'est quelque chose qui est échappe mais
je vais citer un fait que je défends
dans le livre qui pour moi
est du domaine de ce réel qu'on peut pas
changer
c'est une une un énoncé très simple un
pays comme la france ne peut pas ne pas
rembourser sa dette
et comme la france je dirais pas la même
chose si j'étais en italie de cette
manière brutale parce que comme l'italie
à un excédent qu'on appelle primaire
c'est à dire
on appelle primaire déficit primaire ou
excédent primaire le déficit ou
l'excédent qui ne tient pas compte de
l'annuité de la dette le déficit italien
il est entièrement représenté par
l'annuité de la dette le déficit
français il dépasse de loin l'annuité de
la dette on a besoin d'emprunter pour
payer les fonctionnaires et pour payer
les retraites et pour la sécu ce qui est
très différent l'italie à la limite ça
n'arrivera jamais
j'espère pourrait prononcer que elle
fait un moratoire qu'elle remboursera sa
dette plus tard parce que l a pas besoin
d'emprunter pour vivre nous nous sommes
un pays qui a besoin d'emprunter pour
vivre et encore pendant plusieurs années
donc alain minute même où un
gouvernement
déséquilibré
un an serait que nous ne rembourse pas
adepte de la france vous ne trouveriez +
1 euros empruntés et à 7 minutes même le
renouvellement naturel de la dette du
pays puisque on emprunte pour prolonger
la dette
les taux d'interêt passerait à 10 15 20
% donc j'appelle vérité comme dit un art
est ce qu'on ne peut pas changer il ya
une chose qu'on ne peut pas changer si
on veut garder notre modèle c'est
l'obligation de rembourser notre dette
et un tas de gens qui ont pas ça en tête
et des tas de politiques qui pensent
qu'on pourrait éluder cette question il
y en a une autre de l'ordre de ceux
qu'on ne peut pas changer on ne peut pas
fermer les frontières
il ya des gens qui pensent qu'on
pourrait fermer les frontières peut pas
fermer les frontières parce que nous
sommes à la fois un grand pays
importateur
est un grand pays exportateur
si on ferme les frontières on se coupe
de ce qu'il ya de plus forts et les plus
vivants dans notre industrie par exemple
le l'un ds
on vend des airbus c'est formidable on a
cinq ans de carnet de commandes chez
nous on vend des hélicoptères on
fabrique les meilleurs moteurs
d'hélicoptères du monde dans presque
dans mon village
mais si vous fermez les frontières vous
croyez que les autres vont continuer à
vous achetez vos productions
donc je dis on ne peut pas fermer les
frontières ça c'est une vérité du type
de ceux qu'on ne peut pas changer si on
se mettait ça dans l'esprit alors
beaucoup de choses du débat politique
changerait mais vous voyez que c'est en
contradiction absolue avec un certain
nombre de discours politiques qui sont
détenus devant les gens et 7 en
contradiction absolue avec les fausses
promesses qui sont faites en campagne
électorale par exemple ceux des
candidats qui disait on ne créera pas un
euro d'impôt est au contraire on
augmentera les allocations ce n'étaient
pas les mêmes enfin grosso modo ses
proches base dans la vérité c'était
impossible
féminin avant dernière question
on a commencé par un garçon ou une fille
je me souviens plus
ah les dernières questions
à la une
demain
allez on fait une entorse au masculin
fume femina aller ça sera la seule de la
soirée ma question sera rapide vous avez
abordé la question de l'europe le nombre
de pays européens qui connaissent des
difficultés aujourd'hui ne peuvent
attendre entre guillemets de solutions
que par la solution européenne alors
les élections c'est dans un an c'est
pour quand votre livre qui va nous aider
à porter l'idée européenne telle que
vous l'avez d'abord vous allez lire ce
que j'ai écrit dans ce livre bon parce
que je traite de la question ô comme m
comme voilà j'ai trois livres en
chantier alors je ne sais pas lequel
sera finie en premier
comme j'ai la faiblesse de les écrire
moi-même je sais que ça représente du
boulot et donc mais je vous promets de
de m'appliquer à respecter les
directives que moins que vous me fixer
merci à tous c'était vraiment très
sympathique